ladies and gentlemen this is the one and
only Dave Meltzer he is a legend in the
sports marketing world he as an author I
got his books this is one that he
co-wrote with Warren Moon the legendary
football player and another one
compassionate capitalism he was on my
youtube channel a year and a half ago
two years ago something like that and
he's been picking up his game you've
been doing the podcast he wouldn't do an
Instagram doing YouTube really setting
to crush it and David Meltzer everybody
welcome aboard man Thank You Man I'm
trying to be the elder statesman of
social media so I finally found a realm
that I could be the oldest person at now
there's a couple things I want to talk
to you about because the things a lot of
good lessons for entrepreneurs the first
one is the 20 minute rule you've been
you've been talking about this a lot
anybody is like consuming your IG
content you're gonna see a lot of it
tell us what is a 20 minute rule and the
value for the business world yeah
absolutely so you know throughout the
years I created this 520 rule it's my
goal my goal is five-minute phone calls
in 20 minute meetings that's my goal now
there's a variety of exceptions of
course but if you keep your focus on
really making sure that each of your
phone calls are only 5 minutes if
possible every one of your meetings are
20 but most importantly brand yourself
that way what it does is a duality of
one telling people that time is
important not only your time but their
time but 2 it also manages the
expectations when people come in to see
you or on the phone with you because
they already offer mention hey man I
know you're only gonna give me five
minutes and they're much more prepared
so on every level it's more efficient
effective and statistically successful
so when your assistant is booking
meetings for you that's known up front
like a call with Dave is gonna be five
minutes if you're gonna meet in person's
20 minutes yeah and then people can make
exception request right something like
you know for this it's gonna be more
than five minutes then we're gonna go
ahead and go ahead okay how much time
you need let me ask David once a grand
though I'm still building my brand and
my consciousness the time and my respect
for the other person right well let's
try to kind of keep with the 20 just
keep it to the 20-minute rule here
20 minute meetings is a face-to-face
meeting this it's not really a call
because I could see you the other thing
that is a huge part of your brand is
around kindness and gratitude and really
helping people out and not just you but
everybody that I've connected with on
your team is always asking like Evan is
there anything we can do for you
anything we can help with anything at
all like never hesitate to reach out
explain kind of where that comes from
for you and the value to entrepreneurs
yeah so I lost everything I was a
multimillionaire and lost everything and
I lost everything
thinking I was can control and I was a
taker I was a manipulator i over sold
back-end sold I worked really hard right
I still lived by the law of Goya get up
ass but I literally you know I literally
thought I was in control of my own
success and when I lost everything I was
humbled and I decided you know what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna focus in on
providing value and being of service is
providing value that doesn't mean I'm
not working just as efficient effective
or statistically successful I'm not
doesn't mean I'm not working as many
hours I just wake up praying to God that
10 people coming in front of me that I
can help and every business deal I'm my
only concern is how much value am I
gonna bring to this deal and I allow the
value to come back to me
so for entrepreneurs who are trying to
build their name trying to get clients
trying to get partners investors and
well how can they use this what advice
would you give them absolutely so the
best advice is number one is an option
or using this in order to have any type
of impact you've got to stay in business
so don't fool yourself and playing the
game so far out that we're saving look
the key to business as an entrepreneur
is staying in business and allowing
yourself the time to evolve into a
successful passionate purposeful and
profitable business and if you focus in
on the value that you're providing your
family your community your associates
here all of these relations your
investors if you're focusing in on
providing value everything else will
come to that business as long as you're
in business I love it now I want to talk
about about your journey what you're
doing now because there's a lot of
humbleness in what you're doing and
starting over
I mean like in starting Instagram from
nothing and now you're you're closing on
200k in certain youtube from zero
there's a lot of people who don't have
the humbleness to do that because
because you've had I know you're humble
Gaby you've got a ton of success that
you don't you know kind of brag about
and put it on the front cover tell me
why you care so much now about the
podcast you're doing the YouTube channel
you're doing the Instagram like why does
this message matter so much to you right
now getting it out yeah also the TV show
right I have elevator pitch with optical
entrepreneur yep let me explain this you
know what but being a little bit more
experienced if somebody would have come
to me 10 years ago and said Dave there's
a way that 10 years from now that you
can impact a million people a day that
was in my mind like even Tony Robbins
wasn't doing that you would have to have
a daytime show every single day that had
a million viewers to do that three years
ago when I wrote my book and I started
understanding that my ideas could really
help people but I could reach as many I
started realizing wow 10 years from now
if I stick to it in November I had 200
followers on Instagram you just mention
I have 200,000 of approaching a few
short but of truly engaged followers
right these people listen and they but
every single day I'm in front of 200
thousand people every day impacting and
helping a big of service that's since
November my dream was in 10 years to get
in front of a million people every
single day and now I know in 10 years
I'll be in front of million people well
every single person listening right now
to be in front of millions of people
within 10 years if you just start I deal
with a lot of big-name authors who've
written tons of huge books and they're
part of the old school and and they
don't want to get on Instagram or they
know it's there and YouTube they know
it's there but they've written you know
15 books all these bestsellers and
they're kind of just coasting on what
they're doing what was the moment for
you to say okay like this is important
I'm gonna like what happened November
that made you feel Instagram I'm going
to do something big what actually
happened at the Superbowl before is Gary
Vee who's one of my mentors wasn't at
the time I met AJ and Gary at the
Superbowl they were starting a sports
agency
and I offered to be a service I said man
I ran the most notable sports agency in
the world I know all the ins and outs
I'd love to help you guys have a great
reputation I'd love to help you can I be
of service
you know and they wanted me to be a
consultant and help out well then I
started learning what Garrett was doing
and Gary of course being Gary's like
Nate how can I help you right Gary
actually keeps a score chart of help so
he's like how can I help you and so I
said teach me about this Instagram thing
you know I'm unlike the rest of these
older guys you know I don't think you
know there's an audience for me I don't
think I can have an impact he's like
you're dead wrong you know you're dead
wrong let me teach you about content and
he's been guiding me along the way and
then to be honest you're the one that
motivated me for you to write zero
YouTube videos like it right and all of
a sudden if you know you you graciously
said Dave I'll help you here's some
advice and we started following you gave
me a nice little sheet and so you know
it's important to be of service but it's
also important to be humble and ask for
help and I just have to tell you thank
you so much Evan because your help is
invaluable and you are just a gracious
humble and you changed my life
especially with you cool man I mean it
means a lot and and when I saw your
stuff like you remind me of where tom
bill you was like a year ago or a year
and a half ago yeah so my audience we do
my top tens based off of my audience
right my top ten rules of success like
request and a year and a half ago or so
somebody said Tom bill you and like I've
never heard of this guy let me go check
out his channel and and we did something
on him and the first few didn't pop but
I'm like I hope I hope Tom just keeps
going because he's got such a great
message and he did and he's growing he's
over half a million now on YouTube and
growing and then recently like a couple
weeks ago or so somebody said hey dave
meltzer
like dave meltzer man I love that
because we did our interview so long ago
like what's Dave out to you like I
hadn't seen what you've been doing for a
while and I know look at your YouTube
content it's like it's it's good like
for you guys watching and we're gonna
post this on my youtube channel too well
link up Dave's Channel go subscribe
there's so much value I mean for that
for the amount of subscribers
that dave has like you're providing so
much insane value there and and I looked
at as like man I hope Dave doesn't stop
because YouTube is a longer game right
like Instagram is easy to pop quickly
YouTube the thing with YouTube is your
videos from three months ago can still
be fired and still still track for years
we're Instagram it's over in a week
right like nobody cares anymore that's
why I reached out one because like hey
is this awesome like I know this guy I
want to I want to do something with them
but to like I really hope that you keep
going because you have such a valuable
message and it's easy to be to look at
the initial progress and see how slowly
it goes but I know the message works
right it's it worked on stage right yeah
my initial success is you know being the
top top speaker for Forbes an
entrepreneur worldwide so if if I can
hit like I just did Denny's in your
meaning if I'm hitting you know 2,000
people standing ovations why you have
that message be any different on YouTube
and now we're able to capture some of
those put it and if it touches one
person heaven it's fine with me
like honestly like I my vision is
different than most I I don't sell
anything I when I give away my book I
don't even charge for shipping youtube
allows me to perpetuate by my ideas it's
forever in like you said it's a long
game and I'm planning on being around
for a long time and I appreciate you
educating Lovett man well I mean and
it's that humbleness that's so awesome
because I mean I've had offers who've
sold 10 million books and and like the
people who are winning on Instagram are
using hacked versions of those authors
ideas like these are the experts like
you know what you're talking about like
anybody who wants to learn marketing you
need to follow Dave Meltzer like he know
he's been doing this he knows what he's
talking about because of the fall would
count like just building now is the
easiest time to get access and get the
information that they want and so I just
love I love the humbleness and just like
I'm cheering for you man I like if you
ever think about stopping for one second
I call me up like Dave we gotta keep
going man your message is too important
I want to talk about splice yeah I
didn't know you invested into splice I
saw it on your Instagram bio I'm a big
league of Legends fan I know splice
covers like a bunch of different a
splice going to his spice go into worlds
with
the world's we actually got offered at
the permanent League of Legends team
we're number one in halo so but yeah ll
the legal ads is weird cuz it's gonna be
phenomenal it's one of the best
investments that I've made I joke around
that it's gonna allow me to be you know
when I'm really old I'll be yeah my son
my son will be like Steve Jones would be
like my dad's a genius and why why our
European team instead of North America
you know it was really relationship so
Metta World Peace Warren Jeff
Klinefelter's X Piper Jaffray z' guys
Joey Brander Whelan you know just some
of the investors that I knew when they
invited me and I saw the people that
were involved you know you and I both
know I was in China looking at a team
it's a world sport so once you once your
digital doesn't matter where the team is
these guys are all over the place and I
really think of a second thought that it
was in Europe it's got it okay well well
na and Europe have a long-standing
rivalry in league of legends so let's
we'll see who does better we'll see who
does better with worlds coming up people
leaving comments saying Dave is
everywhere Dave is everywhere I'm seeing
Dave everywhere what's the thing like if
people want exposure to your content
your mindset like what where do you want
to drive traffic right now is it your
Instagram your YouTube the show podcast
you know what I think Instagram and
YouTube is a great place to start
because okay I personally good on
Instagram I'm still answering every
single person myself offering books to
them offering advice offering coaching
mentoring where to go how to help it's
taking up a lot of my time and I'm
getting huge return as far as
fulfillment and purpose out of it and
it's really inspiring me so and if
anyone doesn't know you want to check
out just a variety of things just google
my name David Meltzer figure out whether
you like the podcast or the TV show or
the Instagram of the YouTube doesn't
matter to me I'm at Dave Meltzer you can
find me anyway what are you telling your
contemporaries when you're saying you're
spending all this time answering people
Instagram vm's like that's how you're
spending your afternoon or a couple
hours what do you tell them do they
think you're crazy you know tell me what
that world is like you know it's
interesting because they don't think I'm
crazy
anymore they did last year he did last
year when I had 200 followers and nobody
on you to have been right okay where
it's really getting them now is they've
turned into more abundant thinkers and
they're coming to me and asking me how
are you doing this but why did you buy
the media team why did you buy splice
what why are you doing all these things
and I start explaining three things to
him you can sit on stage and write your
books all day long but until you
understand you could write them and
stand on stage but also capture what
you're doing amplify it to four billion
people online with your frequency and
then you perpetuate it like on YouTube
so it grows and grows and growth when I
initially did my first TED talk I think
I had 1,100 people watching right that
was years ago it has more before people
view it today in one day than did it all
the rest of the time right correct and
it'll be even more as my brand grows and
my message gets out there more people
want to see that TED talk I promise you
it's really good
I'm keeping it on the clock I want to I
want to hit our twenty minutes I have
two of your books and I want to give one
away for the YouTube community that's
gonna be watching this video and replay
what do people need to do to get one of
these dave meltzer books from me oh man
you know what I want to know good deeds
so if you can you pick them out if they
can message us their good deeds and you
pick out whoever did the best need that
may be impacted the most people or had
the most energy to it most maybe broke
you up crying but everybody out there
remember it's not the size of meat it's
how many deeds you do so I want to see
what goodies are going on so pay it
forward for Evan and Dave and you'll get
a free book for the people on YouTube
who are watching this leave it down in
the comments below what your good deed
was and we'll pick a winner from there
as well Dave we're bumping up against
the clock you have a final message for
the leave nation yeah
you know my favorite message always is
be kind to your future self which means
every person place or thing that you run
on it run into think about how it
affects your future self and that
includes kindness and includes
generosity and includes honesty and if
you can be honest with yourself and be
kind to others you're gonna live a law
passionate purposeful and as well
profitable life so thank you everybody I
love a great closing thanks Dave really
appreciate some time and thanks for your
advice
I appreciate you Dave is again super
humble an amazing entrepreneur go check
him out on YouTube he's got like 3,000
or 4,000 subscribers that's a
ridiculously low number he brings so
much value you should go subscribe click
the bells a new video every day that you
are going to learn a lot from I'm not
saying that because I'm trying to hype
them up or promote them but like it's
it's actual insane though you're gonna
get and if he is responding to dm's and
responding the comments now this is the
time to get in because he's gonna be in
the millions he's gonna be in the
millions and then it's gonna be a lot
harder for him to to get back to you if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be kind of like a little
beacon if you liked this video and want
more deep Meltzer check out the top 10
we did on him the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there I used to be the smart I
made sure how the smartest guy in the
room yeah now if I'm the smartest guy in
the room I'm in the wrong we're in the
wrong room